Hello there! Perhaps you noticed that
Ms. Coffee Bean is fascinated by lots
and lots of data – too fascinated if you ask me.
With the scaling law paper in Vision Transformers
and now with “How to train your ViT”,
we are seeing impressive performance of big
transformer models on lots and lots of data.
With the release of “How to train your ViT?”,
more than 50,000 models – yes, 50 thousand! –
have been released by the Google Brain team.
Which is great, because these models
do not have to be trained again
and the whole community can start using them!
[alarm sound]
Ms. Coffee Bean, did you sound
the “foundation models” alarm?
Oh, come on, who invited the term
“foundation models” into this video?
Ms. Coffee Bean, we need to talk…
about the question whether ViT
counts as a foundation model, about
the term “foundation model” itself
and about some interesting points we
saw in the foundation model paper,
like the question of "understanding"
and generalization power of
models under distribution shift.
Ms. Coffee Bean, are you ready for this?
Should we also sound the rant warning alarm?
Feel free to skip through the video
chapters when it gets too much.
While reading the abstract of this new...
ah well, who are we kidding?
It’s Machine learning, so this is already old!
I was saying that I was reading the
abstract of “How to train your ViT?”
which explains to us how Vision Transformers
can be adapted to many downstream tasks.
Oh! So this must be one of
these… foundation models, right?
You know, this paper (rather a book)
published by everyone at Stanford
where they rename pre-trained
models into foundation models.
Hmm… but there's no mention of ViT or DeiT,
just a reference among many others to the
paper about emerging properties
in vision transformers, that’s it.
So why didn’t they mention ViT?
Honestly, no idea.
Let’s check the definition of
foundation models to see for ourselves:
“A foundation model is any model that
is trained on broad data at scale
and can be adapted (e.g., fine-tuned)
to a wide range of downstream tasks”.
ViT is trained on more than 300M images,
but is this broad enough?
How broad is “broad data at scale”?
Is something like ImageNet with
1,2 Million images large scale?
I mean, it seems like 2009 it was, but nowadays
ImageNet counts as “academic sized dataset”
and is put into contrast with the hundreds
of millions of images ViT was trained on.
So is ImageNet now big or small?
What scale does the scale have?
Well, let’s suppose that the 300M images
for ViT, a scale that not many have,
is large scale enough. So the condition
of “broad data at scale” for ViT: check.
Second condition: “can be adapted to a
wide range of downstream tasks”. But again,
how should we know from this definition
that this enumeration is wide enough?
What about now? How wide is wide?
Well… How is this definition of any help
in making terminology more accurate?
You see, me and Ms. Coffee Bean have a
love-hate relationship with the term.
Ms. Coffee Bean, the YouTuber, loves it.
I am the PhD student and I am mad at this
as a small bystander to this PR-stunt
that seems to have worked quite well.
Even if there are enough people
in AI who criticize this move,
there are people already happily start to
use this new term of “foundation models”.
Small PhD student rant here,
but was it really a necessity that now every time
one uses this term that fits everywhere and
just replaces some older, non-attributed terms,
all these researchers have
to receive a whole citation?
Ok, but forget about this.
Let’s look specifically at the section
where they explain why they chose the
name they did: They say that this term
“foundation models” will fill a void.
Void I was not really aware of.
We cite “Existing terms capture the technical
dimension”. Because the grandeur of a paradigm
shift is not visible? So their idea
is: let’s replace exact technical terms
through a vague term wich is literary
and metaphoric in its interpretations,
because on one side, we have the confused
researcher about when to use or not to use
the term “foundation models” for
the ViT for example, or ResNet!
But on the other side, the uninformed broad public
-- and possibly supporters of this new “Center
for Research on Foundation Models --,
should suddenly get it, that it is
about models laying a foundation, but that
a foundation does not build an entire house?
This is deep.
Oh wow, I am making Ms. Coffee Bean angrier
and angrier because she does not agree with me.
You know, Ms. Coffee Bean who was created
by a PR move herself, actually loves this!
It's nice, more drama, more PR, more catchy
terms for grant applications and paper titles,
so do not forget to add this one to your list!
Even more, from the perspective of someone
who is not involved in research on these
models or from the perspective of someone who
likes to educate the broader public about AI,
what is really, really great about this
paper is that it is an extensive place
to learn all about these big models for
anyone not closely familiar with them.
It’s like a manual. So, she
wishes your happy reading of
a document where researchers had no space limit!
Now, not really to spare you the reading,
but more to give you some spoilers,
here are Ms. Coffee Bean’s favorite takes from
this book... or paper of 200 pages; whatever:
It was really scary to read the section about
incentives where they say that, we cite,
“Just as the pharmaceutical industry has little
incentive to devote significant resources to the
research and development of malaria treatments,
because poor people cannot afford medications,
the tech industry has little incentive to
devote significant resources to technologies
designed for improving the condition of poor
and marginalized people [Reich et al. 2021].”
So in contrast, universities
are much, much better?
But I don’t know if things are so
black-and-white. When Ms. Coffee Bean
sees the broad-spread aversion of academics
for actually doing science communication
and that there are companies that
do better than described here,
we are not that sure.
Then Ms. Coffee Bean and me both liked the
section on “Understanding” where it is all
about the questions that are going on lately
after seeing how good these models become:
But do they “understand”? Does GPT-3 understand?
We even had a video previously about the
restricted question of whether a text-only system
could ever understand asked by Bender and Koller
and a follow-up on what more is required to get
to understanding, based on a paper by Bisk et al.
The view in the foundation
models paper is a little broader,
with snapshots taken from
different philosophical sides.
And you know, when it gets philosophical, opinions
tend to diverge: The paper tells us that there is
the metaphysical question of what understanding
really means. And then people’s answers diverge.
But supposedly we get an answer there on which
we all agree, then we need to go further into
the epistemological question -- which is a
fancy word for saying that we are unsure,
about whether we would ever be able to
exhaustively test and analyze or dissect
the model to know whether it has understanding.
This means that even if a
model would have understanding,
we would not be able to say whether it does so,
because we might not have the right means
or even the right measure for understanding.
The authors highlight that it’s the same
with intelligence with the Turing test that
has been passed many times already but we
still don’t call those systems intelligent
because we keep moving the goalpost.
We even like to leave the question open of whether
understanding even matters in these models.
Right now, we do not know, and people keep
disagreeing, exactly like me and Ms. Coffee Bean:
My opinion – me, as a researcher – is,
that understanding is a crucial component
for these models. Only then we can trust
them, be comfortable with them and rely
on them when they do difficult things
like driving our cars or caring for us.
And then there is Ms. Coffee Bean,
the incarnation of pragmatism:
She thinks that we do not
need models that understand
for us to comfortably interact with them.
We interact with things that we do not
understand daily: When browsing a website,
most people do now know about
IP-addresses and DNS servers or
any other technicalities of the Internet,
but they use and trust it, nonetheless.
Ms. Coffee Bean thinks that in
the future, at the moment when
these models will get close-to-perfect,
it will all become a risk-assessment:
Supposedly we know from lots of data statistics
that a self-driving car crashed 100 times in the
last 20 years and otherwise was driving
perfectly throughout the whole world.
But we know that there were 1000 human drivers
that crashed due to alcohol consumption or
whatever in the last 20 years. Do we really need
to know that that self-driving car understands
to trust it more and to use it?
What do you think about this? Let us know.
The comment section is for you to crash.
Otherwise, in the paper, it was nice to see
more emphasis put on the data creation process
and the push to create a data hub for
the whole community, because these models
rarely (and by that we actually mean "never")
get any better than the data they are trained on.
Then it is more surprising to see how the
point on distribution shift was set up.
So distribution shift is a point we
really thought we need to discuss.
It’s not about the message itself, with which we
agree, but about how the message is presented.
We cite: “Existing work shows that
pretraining on unlabeled data is an effective,
general-purpose way to improve accuracy on OOD
[which is out-of-domain] test distributions”.
This, and almost every other Machine Learning
talk Ms. Coffee Bean heard, makes it sound like
increasing the amount of training data
increases the out-of-domain performance.
Don't get us wrong, we completely
agree that scaling up the data,
increases performance. But we do not really
agree on this strong emphasis on OOD.
So OOD means that we have types of data that
the model has not seen. This of course in
contrast with "in-distribution (ID)" which
is types of data the model has already seen.
I mean, look at the example here: in-distribution
is satellite data of the whole world since the
model was pretrained on that. Then how is
satellite data of Malawi out-of-distribution
since Malawi is part of the world?
We are OOD sceptics in a sense.
We have not seen these models
perform well out of their
comfort zone, which is OOD. What we have seen
is how expanding the amounts of training data,
the in-domain distribution was expanded a lot too.
We just make the training data so huge
that most of the testing you do is
actually still in-training-distribution.
In other words: nothing will ever be out
of training distribution if the whole
world was seen during training.
And combine this with our incapability
of really imagining huge data amounts,
and we are ready to think that we have created
something more powerful than it actually is.
Why can GPT-3 write HMTL code and perfect
this in few-shot learning? Because it had
HTML code during the pre-training stage already!
But why do we talk about data samples
like they were out-of-distribution
when they are mostly an interpolated version
of a sparsely sampled (in)distribution?
The authors give the example of CLIP
performing well even on ImageNet Sketch.
But of course! It was trained on
400M images from the Internet,
where enough of them were containing sketches!
To us it seems like “foundation models” are not
really a solution to the generalization problem,
since one just completely resolves the
need for generalization by letting the
model interpolate or even specialize
during finetuning, but not generalize.
We do not negate the advantages
of scaling up data; it works
very well to increase the data so much
that everything becomes in-distribution.
But we just advocate for more honesty
about where the performance gains of
“foundation models” actually come from.
If you are looking for real alternatives
and real out-of-domain generalization,
where your model can really handle new data that
is substantially different from what it
has seen before, look in other places.
Someone in this community proposed
Jeff Hawkins’ HTM model. Check it out!
Otherwise, we really enjoyed and appreciated the
section on alignment where the authors say that
“One challenge is the misalignment
between the foundation model’s training
objective and the desired behavior;”.
This really speaks from our heart and if
you want our take on this in relation to
CLIP, watch our video where we highlight
how alignment has already started to be
a problem, when CLIP’s normal behavior,
following its training objective was blamed to
have been the victim of an “adversarial attack”.
Well, wow. This was the video.
Congrats for making it until the end.
But what do you think about
"foundation models"? Let us know
your perspective in the comments to help
settle my divergence with Ms. Coffee Bean!
Do not forget to like and subscribe! Okay, bye!